what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome to where to start a weekly
series where I give you a suggested
reading list for various comic book
characters and teams based on my
experience and this week we're going to
be talking about Batman
so with the new 52 these are pretty
straightforward actually it's pretty
easy to follow for the most part
Batman zero year is where you want to
pick up this is the quintessential
origin I guess or not really
quintessential this is the new 52 origin
of Batman with regards to how it is a
Bruce Wayne steps into this role of
course we covered this with a video so
you're welcome to check that out if you
want to but again this pretty much just
gives us a synopsis of Bruce Wayne
returning to Gotham as he's an adult and
the conflict that he runs into when he's
going against the Red Hood gang he's
discovering this newer criminal element
of Gotham City but it also has to do a
lot with the idea of the people around
him Alfred Pennyworth his uncle Phillip
for example wanting him to step into the
role of a Thomas Wayne and take over
Wayne Enterprises and so again this is
basically just going to tell you this
story's going to tell you how it is a
Bruce Wayne goes from being this blunt
instrument swapping away at other
criminal element in Gotham to becoming a
more precision
I guess surgeon kind of scalpel with
regards to his role and Batman now after
this comes the court of owls now the
court of owls was a stupendously
important story for Batman even if it's
only part of the new 52 I would say this
is one of the most important stories
regarding Batman in the entire history
of Batman comics then the reason why I
say this is because when you look at the
court of owls in the night of owls or I
guess the night of alves being part of
the whole court of owls thing what this
did is it gave us a different depiction
of Batman it told us that Batman has a
breaking point and this breaking point
isn't necessarily Batman freaking out
getting upset or attacking people this
is Batman's it's like a logical breaking
point the fact that Batman can be broken
or at the very least can be put in it I
guess of a state of mind to where he
begins to lose his sanity then that's
what happens in the court of owls over
the course of this event we also find
that Batman doesn't know nearly as much
about Gotham as he thought he did then
this again is very important because of
what it tells us here is that
effectively if Bruce Wayne is going to
be operating as Batman and within the
realm of Gotham City he has to know
everything about Gotham City and the
fact that there was a group called the
court of owls which had been functioning
under the nose of Batman all this time
for generations dating back hundreds of
years and Batman never knew about it
tells us that Batman doesn't know
everything the Batman still has a lot to
learn
now with regards to the older stories
which in truth in my favorite ones I
prefer these a lot we're going to do is
we're going to jump back to 1987 with
Frank Miller and Dave music Kelly I
think it is amusing Charlie I'm not sure
how to pronounce his last name but this
is Batman year one now Batman year one
is considered the quintessential Batman
origin story even by today's standards
this is the origin story that people
cite is saying the best origin story
that was ever written for Batman and
there's a reason for this Frank Miller
is fantastic when it comes to writing
these kind of dark gritty sort of
concepts or dark gritty sort of stories
now from here we jump to the man who
laughs now the man who last was
published by Ed Brubaker and Doug
mackney and 2005 now while this came
long after Batman's Batman year one this
was designed to be the I guess the
direct follow-up to Batman year one this
is taking place directly after that and
where The Killing Joke gives us this
kind of origin to a degree of the Joker
the man who last basically gives us the
first confrontation between Batman and
the Joker so retelling of a lot of
things that we have seen in the very
early comics there's to say Batman issue
number one and so on
from way back in the end the 30s but
nonetheless this is a story that again
simply just starts off this whole
cavalcade starts off this whole
situation where Batman and the Joker
begin this this feud that will last for
decades and decades now after this we
jump to 1988 in 1988 is Batman death in
the family now death in the family was a
very very big story when it happened
this was but this was introduced to us
by jim Starlin and jim a Perrault now
death in the family the reason why it's
so big is because this was the death of
Jason Todd now as far as I understand
that the way DC had done this is they
didn't really know which road they
wanted to take if Jason Todd was gonna
live if he was going to die but he was
going to vacate the role of Robin
regardless of what road was taken and so
they opened it up to fans and they
allowed fans to decide it by a margin of
I think like a hundred votes fans
ultimately decided that Jason Todd would
die now with Jason Todd being killed off
this was Batman's breaking point in a
lot of ways Batman became darker he
became more gritty he became more
violent it was simply an instance for us
to see that Batman despite his I guess
the walls of barriers that he puts up
around his emotions with regards to
other people that in the end he still
does care about these people to a great
degree
now from here we
to the nightfall story arc now the
nightfall story arc is most infamous
because of Bane breaking Batman's back
the fact that Batman had to vacate the
role or I guess we had to vacate the
role of Batman for quite some time then
again this is one of the really cool
things here one of the things that I
think you guys will enjoy when it comes
to the nightfall story arc is the
concept of Bane Bane is he was depicted
in the Christopher Nolan Batman trilogy
and The Dark Knight Rises is not really
accurate at the end of the day that Bane
was still a henchman he was still
basically a guy working for Talia al
Ghul with regards to this version of
Bane in this story this is the
intelligent bang this is the educated
Bane the classical educated Bane this is
the Bane that figured out Batman's
identity and three months I think it was
this is what makes that this is one of
the reasons why Bane became such a fan
favorite is because he wasn't just some
guy who was pumping pumping a toxin that
enhanced his physique that made him
absolutely massive he was a guy who was
a well-rounded intelligent villain and
it was one of the most formidable foes
that Batman had ever faced here now the
last one and the one that I think is one
of the more interesting ones here is the
Tower of Babel
now the Tower of Babel was given to us
by Mark Waid in 2000 and the Tower of
Babel I think was a huge deal and the
reason why was because what it showed us
is that Batman can screw up just like
anybody else and in fact it really
presented this circumstance where Batman
was kind of cast out from the Justice
League as a pariah and the reason why
was because during the Tower of Babel
what Batman had been doing is he had
basically been systematically going
through and analyzing all the members of
the Justice League
looking at their strengths looking at
their weaknesses and trying to find a
way to effectively incapacitate them if
something were to happen if Superman
were to lose his mind how could you stop
Superman if it was Wonder Woman Aquaman
the Green Lantern so on and so forth
this was a way for him to fix that but
the problem here was that Rachele Ghul
had come across this information and had
stolen it and used it to use it against
the Justice League and so again this
gives us another concept that Batman
isn't necessarily this character who is
incapable of error who may have some
faults but in the end always does the
right thing this gives us a really cool
perspective that Batman's screw stuff up
that Batman makes mistakes just like
anybody else
with that being said how many when bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace be sure
to follow me on Twitter there you can
keep up with all the updates from comics
explain and talk to me directly